no I need to know my poker face is that
bad oh please why'd you keep this from
us I think I made a big big mistake
I'm sorry hey everybody its charlie we
need to talk about Noor Allen's mistakes
the producers explained when they're
revealing things and what's going on
when the season picks up so if you're
finding me for the first time there's a
new round of that flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this the good news is as the writers
said that they would reveal Nora's early
big mistakes right away there are a
couple of things that we won't find out
about till later in the season like the
speedforce symbols that they used to fix
Harrison wells from earth-2 at the end
of the season the ones that Barry was
muttering when he came out of the Speed
Force that Nora was writing in the
journal when she was in jitters those
will have something to do with Nora's
storyline the reason why they're not
coming right out and saying it is is
because Nora is trying to solve a
problem in the future which led to her
creating all these mistakes that she now
needs Barry's help for so when slowly
correcting the problem we're gonna learn
more and more about what it is that
she's writing in that journal and what
these symbols mean so the very first big
secrets that we're gonna learn about as
implied by the trailer are why she came
back into the past in the first place
why she's stuck here what her mistakes
were and why it is that she doesn't like
iris so much like she'll do anything she
can to not spend time with iris I
wouldn't go so far as to say that she
hates her mother but she definitely does
everything she can to avoid her presence
it's a really cool thing though is that
the mistakes that she made the problem
that she was trying to fix initially in
the future the reason for her coming
back into the past in the reason why she
doesn't like iris are connected they're
all symptoms of the same problem and it
has to do with what cicada is doing in
the future so we saw cicada in the
present right after this save the Barry
made at the end of the season with
Nora's help we know at least one or more
of his children died he blames Mehta's
his whole thing's this season is that he
just wants to kill all metas so the
worst possible thing that you could be
in proximity to him with that speedforce
dagger is the meta of any kind it
doesn't matter whether you're a good
meta or whether you're a bad meta like
the Rogues are still on this list
just like team flash is on
list the thing about his powers are
is that as a side effect he's
functionally immortal meaning that he
just goes on trying to kill metas into
the future until we get to Nora's time
the producers said that that's 30 years
in the future so I'll talk about Nora's
age too because she's no younger than 24
years based on this crisis date because
you have to assume that right before
this happened iris would have had to
have been pregnant she was conceived
before Barry died and if she's from 2048
that leaves 24 years so she can't be
younger than 24 years old can't really
be older than 28 assuming that she's not
conceived this season let's just assume
for now that Nora's born in season 10 at
some point so she grows up in a time
when it's very dangerous to be Metis so
this is actually something right out of
the comics - Wally West is the first
person in the comics that ever got to
meet Barry and irises children when they
were adults they were the tornado twins
when he met them in the future they said
that it was actually against the law to
be a metahuman so you have to assume
that they're sort of pulling from that
energy even though Nora is an only child
as far as we know right now so Nora is
growing up at a time when it is very
dangerous to use your abilities and
she's born the daughter of one of the
greatest heroes on planet earth so you
grow up hearing about all the adventures
and exploits that your dad had you
idealize him she aspires to become like
him someday but because it's so
dangerous to be a meta we know that she
hasn't become the flash yet because she
had to borrow this jacket to make her
flash suit from iris meaning she's 24 25
26 and she still hasn't got an official
flash costume there's no one to actually
build one for her because maybe Cisco is
dead in the future but at every turn you
have to imagine that iris West knowing
that Barry has died as a crisis or
disappeared like he's just not around so
she raised her as a single mother
iris is probably like please do not use
your abilities I don't want you to die
too so imagine you have the power of a
god you're a teenager and your mother
tells you the only thing you're not
allowed to do is use your abilities
don't be special don't be like your
father
and don't try to go back in time so
imagine some resentment building up over
a couple years until finally Nora can't
take it anymore she wants to fix things
and be just like her father so she gets
the bright idea to
back in time and try to change history
for team flash that's why during each of
her episodes during season 4 she was
visiting different members of team flash
to learn about them develop a plan for
saving them in the future to somehow
change the timeline for the better but
we all know what happens when the Allen
family tries to go back into the past to
change history you get stuff likes
avatar remember how crazy things were
for iris during season 3 because she
thought that she was gonna die at every
turn Barry thought that she was gonna
die that's another reason why iris would
not want Nora to go back into the past
because she'd only be thinking about
what happened with sabot R so Nora's
first big mistakes were in coming back
into the past to try and change things
she came back to visit Barry at the
wedding
then she went back to the future to see
if that had an any effect then she came
back into the past again to visit Cisco
an elongated man she came back each time
then went back to the future so it
wasn't like she was just hanging out of
jitters the whole time she wasn't on
screen but the problem is is that the
last time she came back and she helped
Barry defeat that satellite she found
that she could not go back into the
future she was stuck that's when things
got really really bad so you see with
some of her mistakes were like she's
trying to change the future things maybe
get altered a little bit not quite what
she wanted so she keeps having to come
back to try and make things even better
like okay that didn't work we'll try
something else till finally she's stuck
and cicada is still a very big problem
in the future they haven't solved that
yet so the first big problem they have
to solve is as Nora trying to explain
what she did wrong without giving away
too much information about the future
because she seems really smart so she
probably understands that she can't tell
them everything that happens to them
otherwise that will also cause giant
ripples in the timeline and it'll get
even worse so treading lightly they have
to find out what she did wrong and then
fix that so that she can get back and
then while that happens they start to
encounter cicada so you have to imagine
that Nora is sort of like feeding them
information about the future as much as
they need to without trying to make
things worse so that's why like they
have this conversation in the trailer
during episode 1 Nora how could you keep
this from us so that's her basically
explaining yeah so I came back into the
past I visited all these people but this
is why the thing I'm actually really
happy about is that they explained the
speedforce simple
because we got to the finale and they
just mysteriously fixed Harrison wells
using that without explaining anything
about how they work like we know that
has something to do with stuff that's
happening in the future
like it's almost as if it's an alternate
language that Barry used to interpret
when he came out of the Speed Force
because they decoded and it's basically
just phrases that people speak in the
future it's a little more complicated
than that but that's why they're using
the entire season to sort of explain
that because it'd be like if they got
all the answers at the beginning of
flash season four but there'd be no
drama no tension so if you've been
holding out for what the hell all this
stuff is about they're gonna pay that
off but not till later in the season
they also explained wally west is only
going to be in three episodes including
episode 1 i'm really hoping that he
comes back for the hundredth episode
then maybe like at the end of the season
but they said that because they have to
write him out of the show like that
person that plays wally west wants to go
off and do other things is that they're
gonna have a really cool reason for him
to actually leave the city and not be
around so while he will be on a mission
when he's not on screen even though
that's just a way of explaining why the
actor himself isn't on the show we don't
know exactly what that's gonna be could
have something to do with him going to
earth 3 or earth 2 to help Jesse quick
or going somewhere else in the
multiverse but they'll have some cool
reason for him to not be around so at
least it's not gonna be him just walking
off screen and the writers never
explaining it because that would be a
pretty big middle finger post all your
noir theories in the comments below
there was a whole bunch of comic book
stuff recently so I'll try to get
through those videos as fast as possible
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video the gaming
youtuber not the best very specific
YouTube name please email me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for that new
spider-man far from home teaser and
click here for that new flash promo
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]